um so I'm going to talk to you about uh
tools for personal and population genome
interpretation developed in Python um
actually in they also developed in other
languages but uh most of the tools that
I'm going to talk to you about uh are
are explicitly with python um so um just
to give you a brief introduction uh most
of the the presentation that I'm
presenting here today is on GitHub uh I
will also upload to my python not book
and some data sets that I talked to you
about uh during this talk um so feel
free to download and if you have any
questions just send me a
message um so brief introduction about
me uh this is my first time at a python
conference so take it a bit easy on me
uh this was highly recommended by
friends Olga actually uh suggested that
I that I should join you guys and and
and give an introduction as to what I
with respect to what I work on um I I'm
currently a graduate student at the
University of Oxford my main interest
include the development of statistical
and computational methods for genetic
studies of common diseases and
developing tools outside of that I also
like traveling and uh dancing so if any
of you guys want to dance at the after
party feel free to to interrupt me um so
uh right now as you may well know we're
currently living in one of the
scientific revolutions so in the past
Century we lived in the Scientific
Revolution of modern physics and I think
it's fair to say that this Century or
this decade at least we're living in the
Scientific Revolution of
genomics um and one of the reasons why
this has happened is largely due to the
catalysis By the Drop in the cost of DNA
sequencing so you see this plot here uh
right when I was graduating from MIT the
cost of sequencing in a human genome was
about over $100,000 per uh for an entire
genome and a year before that it was
about10 million dollars to sequence an
entire Human Genome so made it
impractical actually to to do anything
with that data
um so uh two years from 2008 and 2010 I
spent a lot of time working at the Bro
Institute uh what I was doing at that
time during the huge drop in the cost of
DNA sequencing
was developing computational methods
statistical methods algorithms for the
analysis of the raw sequence data that
was being generated uh at that time and
as you can uh probably uh speculate
there was a lot of data being generated
at that time that related to uh DNA
sequencing and we had no clue at the
time what to do with those data sets I
you know first you identified that
there's a whole bunch of errors and then
you need to figure out how you're going
to model those errors and uh improve the
ability to make any inferences from that
data um then after during that during
that time period I decided that one of
the things that I wanted to do with my
life was probably travel a bit more and
also to uh get a PhD so I decided to go
to university of Oxford um uh I went to
England uh and right now the past four
years what I've been trying to do is
just trying to uh finish up my PhD and
uh finish some projects that I worked on
that related to uh uh advantage of the
property that uh lots of genomes were
being sequenced during that time period
And what I wanted to do was to try to
tie that in with uh disease
interpretation um and any health related
tra
interpretation so what's the main
challenge as many of you guys may guess
uh uh the main challenge of of getting a
slew of data is that you don't have any
tools or methods to analyze the data so
you have to innovate at and uh think
about new ways of of processing the data
uh and tying it to the problems at hand
um so as I mentioned before uh uh one of
the topics that that we're trying to
figure out how to uh make inferences
from the data was how to process the raw
reads being generated by the sequencing
Technologies to uh provide to to get
obtaining the best genetic
variation
uh uh reporting the best genetic
variation to to to to perform
research so this is a very arduous
research and Engineering problem so this
is largely has been tackled from 2008
2014 there's still a lot of room for
Innovation improvements as you can see
I've only checked about two out of the
three check marks that it say uh so
right now one of the runes for
improvement include being able to
provide fully phase genome saying
basically this is for any given
individual this is the genotype from
position want to position the final
position of the chromosome uh for the
maternal inherited uh DNA and for the
paternal inherited DNA uh structural
variant detection is actually one area
where there's still a lot of room for
improvement the reason is that we've
only been limited to short read
Technologies and uh in addition to that
right now most of the field has been
focusing on germline mutations or
inherited mutations uh whereas it's
clear that sematic mutations do play a
large role in some disease
predisposition including cancer
um but not exclusively cancer as well so
the tools that I'm presenting have
nothing to do with this actually there's
some nice tools available that I
participated in developing uh during
that time frame including the genome
analysis toolkit and this program called
SCI which was written in Python um what
I'm going to talk to you about is this
next stage which is how to tie in
genetic variation or genetic information
to personal and population genome
interpretation uh and this I would say
uh I if I were to give a check mark out
of three I would give it half a check
mark I think there's still a lot of room
for Innovation still a lot of room for
thinking about new ways of analyzing
these data sets and ways of how to make
inferences about the role of genetics uh
and uh and it's it's its contribution to
disease
predisposition uh and also uh other
related traits that have not measured at
the moment in any genetic study so one
of the nice discussions I had before the
talk was about weable Technologies and
uh just the uh uh Prospect of being able
to tie those two together is something
that's extremely exciting and that
hasn't been done I mean uh been able to
say well this is how physical activity
and genetics ties together that's just
something that that uh just seems
mindboggling that it could be done in a
very near near near time
frame uh so the tool that that that uh
most of the work that I present today uh
is is is largely concentrated or
developed on top of uh this tool kit
called plink seek uh so here is a
picture of Shawn purcel Shan purcel is
actually here in New York City in Mount
Si uh he was previously at MGH and at
Harvard Medical School uh Sean purcel
actually has developed uh other widely
uh used tools and genetics including
plink uh plink has over ,000 citations
and I would uh it's fair to say that it
uh largely made genomewide Association
studies possible these are studies that
uh uh from I would say from 2006 to 2000
or currently are being carried out to
tie it uh common genetic variation and
uh related Health traits um so pling
seek is develop so that uh we can be
able to tie in genome sequence data or
DNA sequence data to
to to to health that up um uh the the
other core developers of plink seek
include uh uh folks like monum uh Doug
ruer uh myself and Brett at at Harvard
uh these two guys are actually here in
New York City um and uh so if if anyone
is interested in in reading more about
what plink seik is and what is available
in terms of tools
uh this is the link this is the web page
uh it uses a VCF as a primary input the
focus is on the analysis of rare genetic
variation but not exclusive to rare
genetic variation it allows for
extensible meta information on Locus
genotypes and individuals to be
integrated uh it's also bundled with PR
reference databases that can be directly
intersected with one's own data uh and
I'll show you some ways that that that
that can be
done and and uh there's a command line r
in a python Library the python Library
um uh this is a python package that I
have developed with extensions to the
plink library uh with Jeff Hammer backer
uh he actually wrote a nice uh uh a
snippet of code for python binding for
some key functions in Python and then
what I did was to take that and extend
it so that we can uh start developing
additional tools and take advantages of
all the aspects that plink seek of of
all the methods that plink seek has to
offer uh so just to give a overview of
what plink seek the the world of pink
seek is like uh there's the command line
interface there's the our library uh an
XM browser and a python
Library uh these attached to a core
Library um which works on top of
variation data and any auxiliary data
including phenotypic information genetic
information sequence information or any
reference databases that that you may
think
of uh just to give you an example of how
we may use this uh toolkit uh or the PIP
pings binding is uh for example here is
a a snapshot of 23 and me raw data so I
ended up getting um um I ended up
ordering a a kit from 23 and me uh
purchased it for $99 and ended up
getting back uh half a million markers
genotyped across the human genome
uh and one of the idea one of the reason
one of the things that you can do with
that data or that 23 can do for you is
to provide ancestry inference I think
now they're not allowed to give you back
any health uh related uh information
back due to uh uh FDA
regulation uh but but they're allowed to
provide the data for you for raw data
download and you as a as a user
investigator as a researcher can go
ahead and and start processing that data
and and making inferences of of uh of
your
genotype uh so this is what the data
from 23m looks like uh this is um just a
flat file and here you'll see rsids
which are identifiers for genetic
markers in the genome uh the chromosome
the chromosome that the that that rsid
is located on the genomic position and
the genotype that the that was called by
by the by the Gen genotyping
technology there's a nice script
available to turn this into a VCF and
and as you recall uh for pip link seek
it works on top of VCF so so you guys
can go ahead and download that script uh
if you end up ordering or purchasing
from 23m or from any other uh genotyping
uh platform
um and uh convert it to a VCF file so
VCF file is the variant call format file
this is a pretty standard file format
file for uh for for
for reporting or or um reporting genetic
data uh so here I just just an example
of what this looks like there's some
nice documentation as to what the
variant call format uh how the variant
call format should look
like uh and here are examples of
commands as to how to work with plink in
terms of setting up a project uh loading
the VC F so this is just an example of
me loading my own uh VCF from 23 and me
and I've uploaded about 922 th000
genetic variants that were available for
the genotype data
um in addition I can start working in
Python uh and working with P plink to be
able to uh attach the databases that are
available as part of plink so you can uh
import pip pling seek uh set the project
that you're going to be working on for
example example I'm working on the
project that contains my genetic data uh
I can print the summary of the databases
that are available so here uh our
example of uh databases that that are
available that are external databases
that are available from uh from uh other
projects for example the locus database
contains information about the
transcript sets that are available in
the human genome and I'll describe a
little bit more how that's relevant uh
there's a sequence database which
basically tells you this is what the
positions or what the what the human
genome looks like uh the reference
database which tells you who has for
example genetic variance at any position
of interest and there's my personal VCF
which I've uploaded to the
project um so as I've mentioned before
you one of the things that you'd want to
do if you're going to interpret what's
going on with your genotypes or what's
if you have any interest in learning
about the genetic variation in your
genome uh one of the things that you'd
want to do is to work with these
auxiliary databases so here's an example
of attaching a Locus database uh so so
once we print uh a summary of the locus
database we can see that there's uh
several uh groups available of
information uh these are basically
referenced transcript sets that are
available uh uh on the human genome and
the idea is that you'd be able to use
this Downstream for analysis
interpretation of DNA sequence variance
so here are four examples of reference
transcript sets that are available uh
it's refseek ccds gen code and
Ensemble um so uh uh in addition to that
another auxiliary database that's
available is a uh a summary of the human
genome sequence uh and that basically
tells you the the the length of the the
chromosomes and also if you want to uh
read or or or find out what the flanking
sequence is of a genetic variant it's
very easy to do
um so here's an example of how we can
use those auxiliary databases along with
your genotype level data to do DNA
sequence variant annotation in PL in
Python so you first load uh a Locus set
so here I'm just going to load uh
refseek so I've done Pi plink seek
annotate load
refseek uh then uh for example this is
just an example of a variant that I
that's on the 23 and me uh array uh you
can also iterate over all the variants
that exist in the 23m array and also
annotate them uh separately uh or in
conjunction uh and and here is just an
example of how you may be able to do
that so you say pipe give a call to to a
pipeling s just do pipeling s. annotate
uh you give it the the chromosome the
genomic position of the variant the
reference Alo the alternate Alo just
basically tells it to annotate it uh and
this is just an empty string which can
be used for other purposes like for
example if you want to find out what
Gene uh is is is is is does that
annotation map
to uh so here you can see that this
particular variant is a nonsense
mutation or a stop gain mutation this is
these are you know in the human genome
or for every individual we carry about a
100 of these nonsense mut or loss of
function mutations uh so these are uh
mutations where uh that Gene partially
functions so you have one copy that
works and another copy that doesn't work
so you can call yourself a a human
knockout version for that copy of the
gene or human knockdown I would say to
be more precise uh and what you can see
is that uh that once we fetch the
genotype level data for that particular
mutation so here is a mask so these
masks I'll I'll talk a bit more about in
the next slide are extremely useful for
fetching data for from from your project
uh so what I've done here is to fetch uh
the variant level data for this
particular variant and what I've done is
to find out what the genotype is for the
individual that's in that project and
what you can see is that zero codes that
that uh that the genotype is uh
reference homozygous which means that
you don't uh have the mutation uh one
means that you're heterozygous which
means that you have one cop Cy of of of
the mutation or the variant uh and two
means that you're homozygous for the
mutation meaning that you have two
copies um uh meaning that you're likely
to have a complete knockout version of
that Gene so here I can say uh that I am
heterozygous for this variant uh and uh
because of the an ability to be able to
annotate the variant I'm also able to
say that uh uh that for this particular
Gene I'm a human knock down version for
Gene X
and there's a lot of interest in
medicine or in Pharma right now for
figuring out what these uh what human
individuals who carry knockout versions
of these genes look like or what they
their phenotypes are like and the reason
is because some of them may have
translational implications for example
there's a nice story of pcsk9 where
where if you look at individuals who
have knockout versions of pcsk and I
they have extremely low LDL levels and
in fact that ends up translating to
having uh strong protection for coronary
heart disease and when you develop a
drug that mimics that that function you
actually have a similar impact on on on
on individuals who who who are on Statin
uh luren therapy so beyond stattin
Lauren therapy it has a protective
effect being able to knock down uh pcsk9
so there's a lot of interest in Farmer
right now and being able to uh interpret
how the phenotypes of individuals who
carry not down versions for any
particular Gene look like
um so uh as I've said before masks uh
are ways where you can easily filter the
data uh with MK intax uh there's a nice
documentation on the plink SE website
about uh how you can use a masks and P
plinks you can easily use the masks
within any of the calls to pip plinks by
by just including it within the quotes
uh so this is used for extracting
information from the various databases
that are available so here is an example
of where we fetch the variant data for
this particular mutation but you can
also say for example just give me the
variant level data for this particular
Gene so if I'm interested in in gene
equals pcsk9 I can write Gene equals
pcsk9 and for the individuals that are
in my project I can find out what the uh
what variants are in that database what
genotypes are in that database and I can
also link that to
phenotypes
um so other applications of masks as
I've said uh you can subset individuals
in a project obtain individuals for only
obtain phenotypes for only shared
individuals you can subset variant based
on some quality control filters you can
subset variant based on population based
calculations so for example if you have
a population of individuals uh one of
the things that geneticists like to look
at is whether the variant is in Hardy
weberg equilibrium and the reason is
that that also gives you some sense as
to whether or not you actually should
care much about that variant or maybe
there's some genotyping errors that that
end up leading to the property that they
are out of Hardy wiberg equilibrium so
hardy warberry equilibrium is just a
calculation for telling you how many
copies of each uh genotype you would
expect to see in a population
um so this also easily allows inclusion
of additional filters so if you want to
include excluded criteria for including
genes variants individuals Pathways or
networks uh you can do that um
so um as I've said before uh one of the
things that we that actually I have been
doing with the PIP plink library is to
develop my own statistical methods
development so instead of worrying about
how to develop infrastructure for
working with genetic data data uh what I
need I can save some time and just work
and just worry about statistical methods
development or ways of interpreting the
data um and and and and in particular
for working with population scale
genomes so this is a a tool or uh uh
program uh developed in Python uh called
that I call Mamba which is uh for
tackling problems in medical genomics uh
so here the this this uh python package
what it does is mostly to to be able to
make inferences when you have population
scale level genomes data um so it's
focused on genetic Association
statistical modeling and uh as a project
to understand the consequences of these
uh knockout mutations uh uh developing
methods for alop specific expression as
well um so just an example of the types
of methods that are are developed in in
PIP plink include this uh uh statistical
test which is we call uh C Alpha MRP and
the idea is that with this Frameworks
it's itical framework you'll be able to
analyze genome sequence data with high
dimensional phenotypes so um so if you
have for example a population biobank
that has multiple health related
measurements collected and you want to
be able to tie the genetics to to those
phenotypes you'd be able to do the
association at the level of Association
at least with this approach uh if you're
looking at multiple disease conditions
uh multiple disease conditions sequenced
uh and you have a set of related
controls of of of controls then you be
able to do the association analysis with
this method as
well um in addition to that uh there's
also Beyond Association one of the uh
implementations uh sorry one of the uh
uh modules that's implemented in in
Mamba includes the ability to estimate
uh estimate provide estimations of
genetic variants that are driving the
association and what phenotypes are
driving uh the association so it's not
sufficient to just say that a gene is
associated to a whole bunch of
phenotypes you also want to know which
mutations are giving right to the signal
and which phenotypes are giving right to
the signal so this is an uh markof chain
Monty call or Monte Carlo algorithm um
that that basically you can see from
this it's fairly easy to run on the data
if you have phenotypes genotypes and the
number of clusters that you'd want to
analyze
then you can run this simple command
after integrating with P plinky um and
it'll give you back some idea as to what
the mutations are doing so this is a
representation of about 10 mutations in
a gene simulated mutations in the gene
uh here uh you can see that there's
three clusters modeled so the mcmc
algorithm what it does is to learn the
Clusters and here it says well cluster
zero we're not expecting an effect for
cluster zero across the four traits that
we're simulated for cluster one we've
learned that there's these are the types
of effects that are observed in the in
the data uh and for cluster two these
are the effects that are observed across
the four different traits and here you
get estimates of the posterior
probability that uh each of the variants
contributes to uh either of the three
clusters so here for example uh given
that I have simulated the effects I know
what's the truth I can see that for
these three variants uh the mcmc
algorithm actually learns that uh these
three mutations uh impact the four
traits in a way that's explained
described by cluster one um here for
these four variants at least for these
three variants I'm extremely confident
that these three variants uh impact the
for traits by the estimates that are
described by cluster zero or the null
cluster and here you see uh that there's
quite some uncertainty to it and and and
and then along you can interpret what
the the next three set of variants give
you so so this is uh approaches for
working with population scale genomes uh
it's fairly easy to run if you have if
you're working with Pip plings and if
you're also working with Mamba um and
and one thing that we hope to do very
soon is to provide a lot of
documentation about these approaches and
and we'll do is to make some data sets
publicly available as well so if
anyone's interested in working with
these data sets or getting your hands
dirty and and developing your own tools
for interpreting personal and population
skill genomes then feel free
to to work on it so if you have an
interest in developing genomics
applications with python feel free to
email me uh and we can chat about it
later as
well
okay